[Music]
we're discussing
on the one hand
shame and guilt white guilt
but those are not the same things as
responsibility and that's why um i made
the point of how
uh you know
the crisis the multi-crises that the
world is going through at the moment um
how much that points us to the
importance of responsibility because i
certainly think we need to move away
from the whole white guilt narrative
that does absolutely nothing for anyone
and in fact an apology that came from a
place of of shame by people who aren't
directly responsible for wrongdoings
it's not as a synthetic apology it's
what it is
it could easily be maybe maybe
my so my brother for instance went to
get a
german passport at the german embassy
which he was entitled to because like
your family
my father's family were persecuted by
the nazis and he thought it would be a
completely bureaucratic procedure and
instead he was welcomed into this grand
state room by a woman who said i want to
personally apologize for everything that
my country did to your family
and he nearly burst into tears it was
the most
wonderful
therapeutic thing now
she hadn't done it but she was taking
responsibility for something her so it
was sincere it was very sincere on her
part
it's a beautiful story which actually
demonstrates how important and
healing and apology can be i just think
on a systemic level i mean when
individuals make those kinds of gestures
they are they definitely can be sincere
and meaningful but on a systemic level
what we're looking for is
is perhaps more than uh even more than
an apology is an acknowledgement because
that involves uh acknowledging that the
wrongdoings are still continuing to
create so much suffering for people
who suffered at the legacies of land
grabbing and land theft so
i just think we really need to make a
distinction between
guilt and responsibility also because
guilt quite often leads to a kind of
uh white guilt specifically uh leads to
a kind of self
flagellating like oh we did such
terrible things and uh you know and and
what's wrong with that
it doesn't um it doesn't mitigate the
suffering that people are experiencing
so i i'm frequently told similar kinds
of comments as your your brother-in-law
did um you know when white people say oh
i feel guilty for the colonization that
happened in in nigeria a country where
i'm from
um
it doesn't i would much rather have a
conversation about what can we do what
kind of institutions could be set up so
that people in nigeria today don't have
to have western waste dumped into our
country so you're saying it's necessary
but not sufficient but i hope you're
saying it's necessary that we should at
least acknowledge
um
and apologize for what happened surely
it's necessary but a distinction needs
to be made between guilt and
responsibility between shame and
responsibility okay so let's move on to
that because having acknowledged i mean
not all nations have some have
acknowledged what went wrong
um
what then needs to be done and is it
feasible to give land back to people who
had it stolen from them generations ago
so i'll start with you on the actual
practicalities of it
um
so
the first thing that's important to
understand is that you know land is
the actual sort of soil that provides
people with food and that
uh that holds sites that are sacred for
people historically in terms of
knowledge and things like that um
is not the same
notion of land that
i think quite often this discussion is
about
you know when we're talking about
borders and boundaries and nation states
so the land itself doesn't care that you
know we call it nicaragua or america or
indonesia these are human denominations
um
and we need to to make that distinction
um
first so that we understand that what we
are giving back is that sense of
honoring the land you know um
yeah
but you do but you actually think we
should be i mean
where does it end as the whole of the us
go back to the indigenous people who
first lived there and owned it
of course not that is invisible so
just practically what actually
practically we set up um so first as i
as i outlined in the beginning first of
all an apology does need to be made an
acknowledgement um and then uh debt
cancellation is one thing that is huge a
huge part of reparations um
and then institutions need to be set up
that are
tackling the political and the economic
uh causes and consequences of suffering
still today and as well as institutions
that are tackling the cultural and the
spiritual
factors that are causing so much
suffering today and we really have to
understand that if we don't do this all
of the crises that we collectively face
we aren't going to be able to meet them
because this this challenge and this
this anger and frustration and suffering
continues to linger um so institutions
is basically uh what needs to be set up
and some of those will will be giving
finances um we'll be canceling debts but
many of them will also be about
encouraging
wellness and and you know even just
thinking about how
you know seeds you know people uh who
are fighting for seed freedom around the
world so that they women particularly
who want to be able to feed their
children organic wholesome food which at
the moment is being targeted only for
you know pretty much for white western
people um so all of these these
questions are are so connected and i
think we need to set up institutions
that are really looking at how to how to
fix that but i noticed that none of
those proposals actually include giving
land back actual physical land back well
that's why i made the distinction
between what we mean when we say it's
not giving a nation back but it is
giving soil back it is honoring sacred
sites it is that they can't till the
soil if someone else is living on it
no but we can um we can see to it that
for example in the amazon you know
indigenous groups are being uh forced
out of where they live those kinds of
things so that's present day since i'm
talking about past sins i land that was
taken away from people 200 years ago
too late to give it back to that as we
know with the kind of palestine israel
question giving land back is in in those
kinds of concrete terms um is a very
difficult thing to do
but um we do have to look at the
alternative ways at least that you know
it can symbolically be given back okay
runner and then eric
i was going to say actually i think
there's an argument
and i claim no expertise on this
whatsoever for a really quite granular
and granular and hard-headed look at
land use because one of the things
that's changed most dramatically i would
say in the last 150 years is the way in
which land broadly speaking if we're
talking about north america in
particular is used in agricultural terms
in partly because the green revolution
and other and also genetic modification
and the way in which crops are actually
grown people i mean the term tilling the
land etc it's a wonderful romantic term
it doesn't really describe the reality
of what agricultural land use is in many
places these days which is very large
industrialized type of farming with uh
you know large uh uh mechanized and
often
large and large use of artificial
artificial intelligence in terms of how
the land is actually actually actually
sown also the types of seeds and so
forth that are to use the current
ukraine crisis shows where one of the
world's great
land uh um advanced agricultural land
uses is currently being destroyed
because of an invasion and a war so it
seems to me that using a law commission
in each particular uh jurisdiction in
which you have a combination of people
who are expert in the existing form of
civil land use law and various types of
indigenous title right which is now a
very well established type of um land
usage uh uh
law regime in a lot of countries around
the world you essentially work out some
version of what that kind of land that
was taken 150 years ago essentially has
in terms of value now and how that can
be equitably and reasonably turned into
whatever it is money education costs um
the ability to actually invest in new
technologies and things which are useful
useful now and you will also get a
completely different outcome in each
different place a country like canada
which has huge you know sort of waving
wheat fields even now and prairie sorry
for the cliche there but you know
broadly broadly speaking too it's
completely different from australia and
i don't want to sort of you know kind of
spoil anyone's illusions here but the
whole the center of australia is
basically desert it is only indigenous
peoples who have had very very long
experience of that land who know how to
work across it travel across it hear it
signals hear its way of life the answer
to australia's land justice question is
going to be a very different one to
those of native canadians and native
americans and i think giving one
universalized solution would actually be
as much a form of imperialism as simply
saying there's no problem there in the
first place at all eric yeah i mean i i
just sort of want to step back to this
question of giving land back as an
as an international norm because i do
think we have to be a bit more cognizant
of the flow of history over time and
over space globally right the flow of
history up until the advent of
international law with starting with
westphalia but certainly going forward
to versailles uh was one of essentially
empires conquering various groups
including hunter-gatherer societies i
mean that was jared diamond's book guns
germs and steel was essentially all
about agriculturalists conquering
hunter-gatherers in africa in north
america et cetera so you have a pretty
bloody history um of territorial
revision and if we're going to go back
and relitigate all that and try and give
land back i mean it's worth saying that
a lot of that is has been behind the two
world wars the start of the first and
second world wars were all about these
grievances about you stole this land we
want it back you didn't give it back
we're going to invade
i mean what are we opening up i suppose
is the question that i would ask right
is that if we're getting people to
marinate in these old grievances i mean
if you look at nothing israel
israel-palestine is one example i mean
the current conflict is another example
sri lanka with the tamils who is here
first whose land is it really we want
things to be the way they were in this
particular year
i just think we're really opening up
we're going into a place that is not a
good place and i think it'd be better to
acknowledge as you say the shame
and sins of the past absolutely but not
to sort of talk about territorial
revision
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas